since we have a little bit of momentum
Can you steal me on the case for
socialism
at that time and even today
I don't know if it's
I don't know if there's a rhyme and uh
similarity to those to socialism is
implemented at that time and what could
possibly be implemented today but maybe
you can dance between the two the Steel
Man arguing for socialism is
if you have everything up to Private
Industry you do not have a guarantee
that someone won't fall between the
cracks and the other concern is in any
other context if someone is let's
suppose mentally ill right through no
fault of their own and they are or
someone's handicapped you know they
can't feed themselves or mentally
disabled or something like that
if you have everything up to charity
some if this you see this with a
endangered species right the species
that are cute it's easy to raise money
for them to protect them some weird kind
of frog somewhere that no one cares
about you can't raise money for it
there's people's interests are to what
they find interesting so if someone is
someone who's like not socially
appealing in some way whatever capacity
they're going to fall between the cracks
and they're screwed under socialism if
you have a government taking care of
everything no one is Left Behind you are
guaranteed that the lowest of the low
and the worst of the worst are still
going to make sure that they're not
starving the street or uh just left
behind so that is a big moral case to be
made for having the state running
everything in terms of economics it's a
lot harder but the argument there would
be it's why it's it's not fair a term
which in my view does not actually have
a good meaning but it's not fair that
because you were born a Rockefeller and
I was born in Poland that you never have
to worry about food for the rest of your
life whereas I have to worry about you
know paying for a doctor for my kid like
you just you won this Lottery when
you're born and now I have to be screwed
and I have to respect all your property
why so
um that is another strong argument to be
made for socialism and the other
argument is if you have a media
apparatus that is operated under
profit-seeking principles it is going to
feed into people's worst
qualities most basic animal-like
qualities and sensationalist qualities
and will be used as a mechanism for
capitalist control whereas if the
government which represents all of this
all of us is running things then
everyone will have a right to have their
voice heard and won't be manipulated
that's the argument what about the
reaching towards the stateless version
sort of uh because you espouse the ideas
of anarchism it kind of has the same
conclusion which is reaching towards the
removal of the state to where we I guess
have uh some distributed reallocation of
resources that are quote unquote fair
but the thing is the the Marxist vision
of the state withering away and uh
becoming anarchism it's really kind of
like um The Underpants Gnomes because
it's like tell me more well step one you
have Mark Tell Me Slowly
I'm sorry you have full communism the
state's running everything including
education step two question mark step
three anarchism so their idea was that
after enough time
the nature of man himself was going to
change changed and then the government
would be Superfluous because we would
all be uh equal and we would all
naturally or socially whatever term they
would use want to act the part that we
would need to do and in fact Reagan had
a great joke about this where there were
two where uh there were two commissars I
think in Moscow and one of them they're
walking around they're going is this it
uh is this have we done it have we
reached full communism the other goes oh
no it's going to get a hell of a lot
worse so you know that's kind of the
counter argument to that